papi I heard your head through this
right I showed you that the first step
was to look at the function you'll be
given break it apart into its its its
components and then put them together
see what happens when you add orders
have a look at Part B see if you can
have a go at that one the heat I'll give
you before you start to draw it up is
that you've been given a subtraction
it's been given a subtraction you've
been given it like this right now
subtraction of ordinates works the same
way except that instead of saying are
one plus one equals two
I'd say one minus one equals zero
something like that okay you can do it
that way if you like alternatively if
you want to use all the tickets we just
developed over the last five minutes
you actually can write this as a sum
what is a difference it's a difference
right now how could I write this so
there's a plus in the middle yeah so
this root X out the [ __ ] is positive no
problem but I can write minus X as plus
negative x yeah for us we're so used to
the way these signs work that we like
there's the same thing but three minus
five and three plus negative five are
actually talking about two different
ideas right this one is about the
difference between two things and this
one is about the sum of two things it's
just that one of them is facing in the
opposite direction now we know because
of we're really good at arithmetic you
know that these have the same value but
they don't have the same meaning so you
can approach this by the way whichever
you'd like to have a go at I'll give you
a few minutes to get a head start of me
and then I'll show you how my drawer now
I pointed out in the first graph okay
this is what it looks like if you're
only going one color but it is loads
easy to do too
and they thinkin a picture soon just
temporarily and if you I'll give it back
to you in a bit
thank you okay so I've done this visit
ecologists night so here are my
component graphs as I said you can if
you like do root X and dou X this guy he
said a negative x and then do a
subtraction but what I find most people
experience is that addition usually is
just words easier to do the subtraction
so this is the way that I've just sort
of steadily doing it do what works for
you okay now this is interesting because
I'm going to do the same addition and
subtraction of ordinates that I did
before but I'm gonna try and push on
your little extra think about this the
first thing I'm gonna ask about is the
first thing I asked over here have a
look at the negative side what's going
on for the domain X is less than zero
hmmm well you get this negative x guy
right he's fine but the square root of x
remember this is the Cartesian plane
it's not the argh and plane okay so the
square root of negative x doesn't exist
you have nothing these are all real
values remember so the root X doesn't
exist over there and that's that's why I
really have this part of a graph okay so
in order to have the whole function you
need to have each of the bits of the
function okay so therefore since this
guy doesn't exist that the whole thing
does not exist over here okay so I don't
need to draw anything on the left-hand
side yeah that's the first thing I would
notice the second thing is then I can
say well now my ordinates begin
somewhere right at x equals Europe so
what are both ordinates equal to at x
equals zero
and it's a zero so that's cool that's a
nice easy one to pick out right and now
I'm going to start to move off to the
right so for example if I just go and
integers right if I go x equals 1 x
equals 1 what is the ordinate of red X
it's the square root of 1 which is 1
okay so I'm just going to put up a
marker there for 1 so up here the
ordinate is 1 ok what's the
corresponding ordered it on the other
part of the graph
it's negative 1 because x equals 1 and
this graph is y equals negative x right
so when I add those ordinates together
what's gonna happen huh okay but as soon
as you go a little bit further things
start to get more interesting now
because that's the root X function I I
don't want to do 2 or 3 I'm gonna go
straight to 4 because it's a square
number so I'm just gonna get something
neat out of this right you can pick any
value to your life I might as well pick
one's another convenient emit so this is
0 and then 1 I guess
2 & 3 & 4 I've gone off there but you'll
see I've got enough detail when are your
x equals 4 what is the ordinate up here
it's 2 and my scales reasonable that
looks about twice as high
correspondingly the ordinate down here
will be yeah negative 4 right so when
you add them together to negative 4
you're gonna get negative 2 aren't you
sir instead of being here I look like
I'm gonna be somewhere like that okay
now here's where I'm pushing on your
little box you you add the ordinance but
this starts to get tiresome quiet
quickly in here you look like you're
quite close together these guys are sort
of fighting with each other you can
always think of them kind of like a
tug-of-war and things seem to be locked
in place but then down here things
things start going that way right and if
I go further x equals 9 for instance
right this is gonna be 3 and this one's
gonna be negative 9 right so this guy is
winning
why is he winning what is it about the
graphs what geometrically tells me that
this guy will win and discover will lose
yeah it's a greedy it's about steepness
right so this guy has a constant green
is negative 1 all the way okay
well it's happening to the gradient of
this it's decreasing
I never goes name if it never drops back
down but he's slowing down and slowing
down forever you can of course actually
confirm this because we'd have
right if I want to differentiate this I
wouldn't write as root next how would I
write it X to the power huh right so
when you differentiate that what do you
do with that power do two things right
you bring it out the front bring out the
front so it's gonna be half and then you
reduce this by one right so that's going
to become this
yes now I've put it in the next four so
I could differentiate it but now I'm
gonna put it back into a nice neat form
into radical form that's one on to
redact
okay so you can see as X gets a bigger
bigger - bigger what's happening to this
this is the great it gets smaller and
smaller and smaller
okay so I guess if you wanna think about
this in tug-of-war terms which is a
helpful metaphor to have this guy just
keeps chugging on any giant somebody
doesn't stop never gets tired
whereas this guy's like uh I want to go
home I'm getting progressively more
exhausted so that's why this guy wins
okay so I know I'm heading down that way
and I'm also gonna head down which D
Prince debug right the last question is
what's happening in here because I don't
actually know right so I've got I've got
two things that I could do here right
number one I could just add ordinates
like I did before right so for example
if this is zero and one
what's the matter you'd like me to put
if you have it off half will work so if
I go for a half in there I know what the
ordinate here is be negative 1/2 okay
what would the ordinate on top be this
is um this is really a mystery so this
will be root 1/2 which is 1 on root 2
which is does anyone know what one other
two is Corps this is treats at Maui from
memory I think it's about 0.7 okay you
go check it out with your calculator
okay but the important thing about it is
that point seven is fighting with
negative point five right there's
negative half that's what we said before
so who's winning in this little patch
rude X is winning right and you can kind
of see it can't you can you visualize it
look he starts off steep he starts off
so well right and then it's later on he
gets tired whereas this is our this is
our tortoise right the slow and steady
and he never suspends up never slows
down so what you're getting up here this
is the value of it
this is like 0.7 versus negative 0.5 so
point to put you so what's your good
again I let's the touch to get the real
thing yeah I shall draw and then we'll
confirm it is you're getting this kind
of behavior like that and if I show you
this you can't see what's going on okay
so I'll zoom in a little bit you see
what's happening there is in fact a
stationary point there right now you're
not expected to find the stationary
point at the moment but um you had to
know there was a stationary right how
could you go even before I showed you
that it was there figure out the
features right initially this guy's
winning lose meaning but it doesn't last
very long this guy eventually takes over
well what we call that if you're going
up and then you're going down we called
that a turning point right and these
graphs are continuous so it's not like
it's not like a shop thing like this so
therefore there must be some point on
which the derivative is zero okay you
can find that by calculus you can verify
okay